« Vous devez apprendre les règles du jeu.
Puis vous devez mieux jouer
que tout le monde.
»
— Einstein
C’est bien de connaître
un cours de trois cent pages par cœur,
de connaître
des références originales,
des belles citations
— c’est bien beau tout ça,
mais c’est quoi
LA BASE ?
LA BASE,
c’est de connaître
LES RÈGLES DU JEU.
Vous voulez réussir
vos dissertations de culture générale
en Prépa HEC
et aux concours
des écoles de commerce ?
Alors vous DEVEZ
connaître les RÈGLES DU JEU
de cette épreuve.
L’épreuve de dissertation de culture générale
en Prépa HEC,
je la connais bien,
parce que j’y prépare des élèves
depuis une dizaine d’années.
Et chaque année,
je leur reproche
LA MÊME CHOSE :
ils ne connaissent pas assez,
voire PAS DU TOUT,
les RÈGLES DU JEU !
Or,
je vous l’ai dit :
c’est LA BASE !
Qu’est-ce que c’est que
la « culture générale »
en Prépa HEC ?
Quel est le programme ?
Quelles sont les consignes PRÉCISES,
OFFICIELLES,
de l’épreuve ?
Quelles sont les statistiques des notes
aux concours,
et les coefficients ?
Vous DEVEZ connaître
les réponses à ces questions.
Ça tombe bien :
je vais TOUT
vous expliquer
CLAIREMENT
et SIMPLEMENT
dans cette vidéo.
Mais avant de commencer,
je vous invite à vous inscrire
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail
très simple
et très pratique.
Regardez ce que les élèves de Prépa HEC
en disent :
Bon,
revenons aux règles du jeu.
Qu’est-ce que je veux dire par
« RÈGLES DU JEU » ?
Je vais vous dire dans cette vidéo
ce qu’est PRÉCISÉMENT
la culture générale en Prépa HEC ;
les MODALITÉS
de vos épreuves de dissertation ;
et enfin,
la NOTATION
et les COEFFICIENTS
appliqués aux concours.
Vous savez combien de temps
ça m’a pris
pour rassembler toutes ces informations ?
Une après-midi ENTIÈRE
(j’ai même appelé HEC
pour obtenir des statistiques).
MAIS VOUS,
vous saurez TOUT
ce que vous avez besoin de savoir
en seulement dix minutes,
en regardant cette vidéo.
Donc regardez-la attentivement :
éteignez votre téléphone,
préparez-vous à prendre des notes,
et concentrez-vous.
C’est parti !
Commençons par le commencement :
que dit le programme officiel ?
L’arrêté du 30 mai 2013 dit
que l’enseignement de culture générale
A TROIS OBJECTIFS majeurs :
« Il vise à développer chez les étudiants
la maîtrise de l’expression écrite et
orale
ainsi que l’aptitude à communiquer,
compétences indispensables
pour leur future vie professionnelle.
[TIENS TIENS
ça ressemble beaucoup à ce que je répète...]
Il les entraîne à approfondir leur réflexion
personnelle
et leur sens critique.
Il leur permet d’enrichir leur culture
et de mieux comprendre le monde
dans lequel ils vivent.
»
En synthèse,
le programme dit :
mieux s’exprimer
— à l’écrit
et à l’oral ;
mieux réfléchir ;
et mieux comprendre le monde.
Donc,
contrairement à ce que semblent croire
certains profs,
le but n’est PAS DU TOUT
de connaître DANS LE DÉTAIL
les théories de Platon.
En termes de « culture »,
le but c’est,
comme le dit l’économiste Jean-Marc Daniel
— qui était prof à l’ESCP —
le but c’est de former l’esprit
des « FUTURS OFFICIERS
DE LA GUERRE ÉCONOMIQUE » :
de leur apprendre à réfléchir avec rigueur,
à manipuler des idées complexes,
et de leur donner
une certaine ampleur de vues.
Eh bien oui,
une école de commerce,
ce n’est pas pour faire prof de philo !
D’ailleurs,
la matière « culture générale »,
ça ne se réduit pas à la philosophie
— en Prépa HEC,
c’est un surtout mélange de philosophie
et de littérature
— comme le précise le site d’HEC,
d’ailleurs —
mais en réalité
TOUTES LES CONNAISSANCES
qui permettent de MIEUX COMPRENDRE
le monde
sont pertinentes.
L’histoire,
l’économie,
la psychologie,
le droit,
etc.
plein de connaissances différentes
ONT donc leur place
dans cette matière.
Voilà pour les lignes directrices
de la culture générale en Prépa HEC.
Maintenant,
quel est le programme de la matière,
c’est-à-dire qu’est-ce que vous êtes
censés
APPRENDRE
en culture générale en Prépa HEC ?
Alors,
ce n’est pas la même chose
en PREMIÈRE
et en DEUXIÈME année.
En PREMIÈRE année,
les cours de culture générale
servent à consolider
et à enrichir
le socle de connaissances
constitué au lycée.
De ce point de vue,
la matière est un peu le PROLONGEMENT
du français étudié jusqu’en première
et de la philosophie étudiée en terminale.
Voici le programme précis
de première année :
L’héritage de la pensée grecque et latine
Les apports du judaïsme,
du christianisme
et de l’islam à la pensée occidentale
Les étapes de la constitution des sciences
exactes
et des sciences de l’homme
L’essor technologique,
l’idée de progrès
La société,
le droit et l’État modernes
Les figures du moi
et la question du sujet
depuis la Renaissance
L’esprit des Lumières
et leur destin
Quelques grands courants artistiques et esthétiques
depuis la Renaissance
Les principaux courants idéologiques contemporains
Alors oui,
ça fait beaucoup,
mais on ne va pas se mentir :
la plupart des élèves de Prépa HEC
ne retiennent pas grand chose
de ce programme.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien parce qu’il y a UN THÈME
en deuxième année.
Les différentes banques de concours
se mettent d’accord sur un seul thème,
si bien que
TOUS les sujets des concours
porteront sur le même thème.
Par exemple,
c’était « le désir » en 2020,
et c’est « l’animal » en 2021.
Du coup,
ce n’est pas très rentable
de maîtriser le programme de bizuth.
Maintenant,
qu’est-ce qu’on peut dire
des thèmes qui tombent ?
Eh bien,
ça varie :
ce sont parfois des notions
très classiques
et vastes
— qui sont même
au programme de philosophie de terminale,
comme la science en 2007,
ou la nature en 2016 —
MAIS la notion est parfois précise,
comme la sensibilité en 1999,
ou la beauté en 2009.
Globalement,
ce sont toujours des idées classiques
en philosophie.
Voici tous les thèmes qui sont tombés depuis
1991 :
Voilà,
maintenant que vous savez
ce qu’il faut savoir SUR LA MATIÈRE,
je vais vous parler de L’ÉPREUVE :
la DISSERTATION
de culture générale.
Soyons pragmatiques :
voici à quoi ressemblera le sujet
le jour J,
au concours.
Bon,
on n’apprend pas grand chose sur l’épreuve
en lisant le sujet.
On lit qu’elle dure quatre heures,
en l’occurrence de 14h
à 18h.
Lisons aussi le Nota Bene :
« Il sera tenu compte des qualités de plan
et d’exposition,
ainsi que de la correction de la langue.
Il n’est fait usage d’aucun document
et l’utilisation de tout matériel électronique
n’est pas autorisée.
»
Le sujet rappelle donc
ce que dit le programme :
le plan,
c’est-à-dire l’organisation de la pensée,
et l’expression écrite
sont importants.
Et puis pas de document,
ni de matériel électronique.
Alors,
ça c’est un sujet tombé à l’épreuve
du concours d’entrée d’HEC,
mais comme vous le savez probablement,
il y a TROIS épreuves principales :
celle des écoles HEC
et EM Lyon,
qui compte aussi pour d’autres écoles ;
celle des écoles ESSEC et EDHEC ;
et enfin
celle de la banque de concours ECRICOME.
L’épreuve ECRICOME a généralement lieu
à la mi-avril,
puis celles de la BCE se tiennent fin avril
début mai.
Quelles différences y-a-t’il
entre ces épreuves ?
Ce sont toutes les trois des dissertations
de culture générale
à rédiger en quatre heures,
MAIS les sujets HEC - EM Lyon
et EDHEC - ESSEC
sont généralement plus difficiles.
Tiens,
prenez trente secondes pour regarder
les sujets tombés ces dernières années.
Autre différence
entre les trois épreuves :
à ECRICOME,
vous aurez le choix entre un sujet qui porte
sur le thème
et un sujet HORS-thème,
qui porte sur LA TOTALITÉ
du programme de première année.
Alors,
les sujets de ces trois épreuves sont différents,
mais ces épreuves partagent
LES MÊMES conventions.
Retenez-en surtout deux.
Les correcteurs s’attendent à un plan dialectique
en trois parties,
avec trois sous-parties
— soit neuf parties au total.
Ce n’est pas obligatoire,
mais vous prendrez un risque inutile
en adoptant un autre type de plan.
La seconde convention,
c’est de souligner les références
pour permettre au correcteur
de les repérer facilement dans la copie.
Voilà,
vous connaissez maintenant
les CONSIGNES de l’épreuve,
les différents SUJETS,
et les CONVENTIONS
de l’épreuve.
Il est temps de parler
DES NOTES
et des COEFFICIENTS.
Comme toutes les autres épreuves,
la dissertation de culture générale
est notée sur vingt.
MAIS étant donnée sa difficulté,
les résultats sont habituellement INFÉRIEURS
à ceux des autres matières.
La différence importante
avec les autres épreuves,
c’est que le correcteur
de la dissertation de culture générale
est LIBRE
dans l’appréciation de la copie.
Il ne suit pas un barème précis
(à ma connaissance),
ce qui renforce l’idée de la « loterie
».
Le jury ECRICOME le dit explicitement :
« Il n’y a pas à proprement parler de
BARÈME
pour la dissertation de culture générale.
»
Donc si le correcteur vous a à la bonne,
il peut vous SURNOTER ;
et inversement,
s’il ne vous sent pas,
il peut VOUS SACQUER.
C’est POUR ÇA
que j’apprends à mes élèves
à écrire CLAIREMENT :
un style CLAIR,
c’est LE MEILLEUR MOYEN
de SÉDUIRE le correcteur,
et donc d’être SURNOTÉ.
Et inversement,
un mauvais style fait PERDRE
des points.
Dans Je vais vous apprendre à intégrer HEC,
Emmanuel Vayleux parle
d’une « DOUBLE PEINE » :
« Il est fréquent qu’une copie présentant
un style fautif
soit SANCTIONNÉE
au-delà même du barème prévu à cet effet.
Difficile effectivement pour le correcteur
en charge de noter une copie fautive
de dépasser l’a priori NÉGATIF
qu’ancrent dans son esprit des fautes constantes
et il est fréquent que les erreurs de forme
se paient également en termes de crédibilité
sur le fond.
Le tout se répercute,
bien évidemment,
sur l’impression générale que donne votre
prestation,
et donc sur la note finale.
»
Donc rappelez-vous :
le correcteur est libre,
c’est à vous de le SÉDUIRE.
Parlons NOTES
maintenant.
Que disent les statistiques ?
Je ne vais pas aller dans le détail
— ça ne sert à rien —
je vais vous donner les grandes lignes
pour ces dernières années.
Aux épreuves HEC - EM Lyon
et EDHEC - ESSEC,
la moyenne est grosso modo
autour de 10
pour les ECS et les ECE,
et autour de 7
pour les ECT.
Vous pouvez aussi retenir
qu’entre un élève sur dix,
et un élève sur sept
décroche plus de quinze.
Autre information intéressante :
environ un élève sur deux cent
décroche LE GRAAL :
vingt sur vingt.
Eh oui,
comme vous le savez probablement,
les notes sont ÉTIRÉES
aux concours :
ça permet de DISCRIMINER
les candidats.
Les correcteurs étaient traditionnellement
sévères
en culture générale,
mais depuis les années 2000,
les jurys font en sorte
de donner davantage de BONNES NOTES
pour que la moyenne de la matière
soit comparable
à celles des autres matières.
C’est pour ça qu’au doigt mouillé,
un élève sur six d’ECS / ECE
atteindra la barre d’admissibilité à HEC
et à l’ESSEC
en culture générale
— c’est-à-dire,
en termes de notes,
treize quatorze.
Ça montre que ça n’a
RIEN d’impossible,
d’atteindre la barre d’admissibilité
en dissertation de culture générale.
Par ailleurs,
c’est encore moins difficile
d’atteindre les barres de l’EM Lyon
et de l’EDHEC,
qui sont grosso modo
à douze et demi.
MÊME les candidats les plus faibles peuvent,
en étant réalistes,
viser la moyenne
pour « sauver les meubles ».
Quant à l’épreuve d’ECRICOME,
la banque ne communique pas les statistiques
(à ma connaissance)
— mais j’imagine
qu’elles disent grosso modo
les mêmes choses
que celles de la BCE.
Alors après,
il y a NOTE
et NOTE.
Je veux parler des COEFFICIENTS !
Eh oui,
votre note
en dissertation de culture générale
N’AURA PAS
le même poids
dans toutes les écoles.
Là aussi,
il y a pas mal de spécificités,
donc je ne vais pas
entrer dans le détail,
mais seulement vous donner les GRANDES lignes.
Qu’est-ce que vous pouvez retenir ?
Vous pouvez d’abord retenir que
les écoles qui accordent
le PLUS GROS coefficient à l’épreuve
sont HEC
et l’ESSEC,
et puis KEDGE.
Ensuite,
vous pouvez retenir que
les écoles qui accordent
le PLUS FAIBLE coefficient
à l’épreuve sont :
GRENOBLE École de Management,
TOULOUSE,
AUDENCIA,
SKEMA,
et
MONTPELLIER.
Après,
le coefficient change non seulement
en fonction de l’ÉCOLE,
mais aussi en fonction de la FILIÈRE
— donc ça fait BEAUCOUP
de coefficients différents !
Pour simplifier les choses,
vous pouvez retenir
que la dissertation de culture générale
pèse grosso modo
UN SIXIÈME
de la moyenne des concours.
Dans la hiérarchie des épreuves,
elle passe après les mathématiques,
l’économie
(pour les ECE),
la géopolitique
(pour les ECS),
le management et sciences de gestion
(pour les ECT),
et elle est placée sur le même niveau que
la LV1
par certaines écoles
(AUDENCIA,
par exemple).
C’est grosso modo
LA TROISIÈME épreuve
la plus importante
des concours.
Voilà,
vous savez TOUT
sur la dissertation de culture générale
en Prépa HEC.
Si vous deviez retenir
uniquement TROIS CHOSES,
je vous dirais de retenir
que l’expression écrite
est une dimension FONDAMENTALE
de cet épreuve ;
que la note compte GROSSO MODO
pour un sixième
de la moyenne aux concours
— MÊME SI,
comme je vous l’ai dit,
le coefficient selon les écoles
et les filières ;
TROISIÈME CHOSE à retenir :
vous avez vu les sujets,
c’est une épreuve DIFFICILE,
vous ne devez donc pas
la prendre à la légère,
sinon vous allez vous ramasser.
En particulier,
vous avez besoin
d’une méthodologie SOLIDE.
Inscrivez-vous donc
à mon cours GRATUIT de méthodologie :
vous pouvez vous y inscrire
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Bien sûr,
si vous avez des questions
sur la dissertation de culture générale
en Prépa HEC,
n’hésitez pas à me les poser
dans les commentaires,
et je vous répondrai avec plaisir.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous sera UTILE,
parce que,
comme le dit EINSTEIN,
il faut connaître les RÈGLES DU JEU
pour mieux jouer que les autres.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour CARTONNER
en dissertation en Prépa HEC.